hello there it's fortnite update day yet
again and like usual i'm here to go over
all the map changes and story secrets
you may have missed we also have answers
to questions we had last time we met
which could indicate what's going to
happen over the next few updates or even
seasons i'm adam maru i have a creator
code if you'd be so kind and let's do
this
the new update is centered around the
seven's resistance against the attacking
forces of io the blue and red lines on
the map have been adjusted slightly to
tell us that the fight back is well and
truly on and two major events are
happening first in game right now you
can see the fight for the old volcano io
and the seven are scrapping in the
streets over the daily bugle this takes
place over three rounds and ends with a
boss fight each side uses rifts to bring
in additional troops until either io or
the resistance win and the cool thing we
see is the emoting after a hard-fought
victory for science i tried to fight for
the i io but it's not possible you can't
hurt them we've got to stay with the
resistance and get used to this because
we're going to do it many times over the
season this process is going to take
place at other pois as we take them out
of the imagined orders hands the
progress of the fight back is already
visible on the map in the north look to
the horizon and you should see a plume
of smoke get close enough and you'll see
an io tower now reduced to nothing this
spot is important as it's the location
of sloan's first drill which appeared
back in december this is the first point
i'll reach this side of the island and
now it's been taken back by the
resistance
for me the biggest thing in today's
update is the full return of these guys
the rock family one of the things
noticed in the first week was over in
the desert strange rock formations were
growing underfoot it didn't take the
community long to glitch under the
island to reveal the return of the rock
family chapter one's love story in fact
story time
picture the time it was season seven of
chapter one the snow biome had just
arrived and the volcano was about to hit
the island over three years ago two rock
formations appeared and looked at one
another from afar slowly over the next
three seasons they actually managed to
get to each other painstakingly slowly
walking together each update until the
moment they met and not even molten lava
could keep these two apart they were
named sharon stone and rock the dwayne
johnson which is strange to think about
now by season 9 they had created their
own farmstead and lived happily with a
child we named him kid rock life was
perfect one day that sprog went for a
walk and decided to pick a flower
disaster struck when he fell from the
edge and only clinged on by his
fingertips all this while his parents
watched on in fear luckily a stone dog
aka a rock viola thank you was walking
by merrily urinating on trees like we
all do he spotted the kid and somehow
saved him this completed the family we
couldn't wait to see what happened next
and a black hole happened so we had to
wait and only two weeks ago the stone
family was spotted once again today the
family have clambered free ready to
restart their life mother and son are
embracing and dad is trying to pull the
dog out of the sand i can't believe how
invested we are in static rock
characters
fortnite does funny things to us let me
know your guesses and what they will do
next i have a feeling this could go on
for seasons
last week we started a new series called
weird easter eggs i don't understand yet
and without a doubt you guys knew
exactly where that easter egg was from
for those that didn't know this little
car crash easter egg is indeed in honor
of the misadventures of rust 9k and his
teammate who decided to use a rift in
their whip only to put themselves six
feet under the map rest in peace the
second grave site which is quite near to
the stone family right now is to honor
jack graz and his squad who used the old
tire glitch to eat themselves over a
huge portion of the island but it didn't
go too well for jack who landed right
here before his demise both grave
locations remain in the game this week
and there's a new easter egg for you to
try and help me out with just outside
kony there are two vehicles completely
destroyed as if they've crashed into one
another this could be just window
dressing for the impending fight at this
location or it could be another player
salute do you know the importance of
these two cars if you do please let me
know in the comments i'll be sure to
spread the word next time another update
we need to recover is hidden in a bush
near this gas station does this thing
ring any bells
[Music]
again this could be nothing at all or it
could be the subtle return of the bear
in a chair from chapter two back then a
bear sat in a chair for seasons and then
suddenly a strange phenomenon happened
that bear and that chair somehow shrank
each update week after week the chair
became smaller and hashtag tiny chair
became the thing it was incredibly tiny
by the end of the chapter is this the
same bear on a chair i'll be sure to
check on this each week and let you know
and it is another strange update which
completely baffles me at the start of
the season the impossible rock sat
proudly and suddenly a container was
added to it many people told me to keep
an eye on this and i was like yeah okay
buddy well they were right this week
that rock formation has yet another
haulage container on it is this
important probably not could this grow
into an obscene work of art hopefully
yes the rock below is indestructible so
this may be a way for epic to overload
it and bring it down in a future update
and speaking of future updates take a
look in the snow right now and you'll
see the return of the hibernating combo
piles we thought they were all gone but
it looks like colombos are coming back
very soon so expect more combo click
bait from your favorite youtube cringe
creators it's gonna be good
without a doubt one of the coolest
details to me at least since the season
started are the locations of the food
supplying npcs like guacao tomato head
and peely they've all been recruited by
the resistance and stay behind enemy
lines some hiding and some living quite
normally what's great is the rooms that
they stay in even though they are far
from home their room fits them for
example man cake has moved away from the
butter barn and set up home at rocky
reals he has comms equipment and tech
from the seven to confirm he is part of
the resistance but look at the room too
he's brought with him his favorite piano
and there's a lantern and other things
which represent the butter barn io's
occupation of coney and the ice cream
parlor has led to that attendant living
above a bookshop and once again he's
surrounded by the things he loves ice
cream peeley's new home in the daily
bugle poi is decorated just like only he
could ever want it to be and all the
other ones too the attention to detail
is wonderful and their time is coming
the fortnite dev who did this could have
put these characters anywhere they
wanted but they didn't they thought
about where they were going to stay and
what it would look like and i think that
deserves our respect i was expecting
io's fortification of some pois to grow
this week but it seems like they're the
same as last update sadly for example
the io over at tilted towers were
planning to put up a new imagined order
banner the little forklift trucks were
ready to go and they're still in the
same place this week rip this week we
did see the reveal of the bonus reward
skins for people who have the battle
pass and oh my god i like these so much
so it looks like i'm grinding to level
200 again okay i've started waffling
which means time to end the video i
think that's everything of note this
week please let me know on twitter if i
missed anything here's a list of code
adamaru legends who are kind enough to
use my code and let me call what i do a
job i really appreciate thank you so
much i'm adam you're awesome i'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]